تفاعل واسع مع الحرب على المخدرات في
السعوديه
وعنصريه مطعم ضد المحجبات تثير الجدل في
مصر وصدمه من عرض ام لطفلتها للبيع على
فيسبوك اهلا بكم الى تفاعلكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الحرب على المخدرات عنوان امتلات
به منصات التواصل والحسابات الرسميه
وغيرها الرسميه في السعوديه حيث تخوض
المملكه حربا دروسا شكلت تجربه فريده من
نوعها في محاربه كل من يتاجر بالمخدرات
ويروج لها ويتعاطا اطلقت حملات متعدده من
بلغ عنهم وبالمرصاد وخلق قريب وغيرها من
الحملات داخل السعوديه والتي طالبت خلالها
المجتمع المحلي بالاشتراك فيها والتعاون
مع السلطات المعنيه راينا كيف تم ادراجه
حرب السعوديه على المخدرات ايضا ضمن
الاعمال الدراميه في الموسم الرمضاني
والتي شهدناها في احدى حلقات المسلسل
الشهير طاش العوده والتي تناولت خطر
المخدرات على حياه الشباب والتي لقد
تفاعلا منقطع النظير امس انتشر مقطع فيديو
للفنان فايز المالكي تم تداوله بشكل واسع
جدا
ظهر فيه وهو يتكلم عن خطر المخدرات وقال
انها هلاك وضيع وتدمير للفرد والمجتمع
وطالب كل من يرى مدمنا ومروجا للمخدرات
الابنه عنه مباشره
يا جماعه
عادي ترى معين
هلاك ضياع اللي ياكل منها لا يتوقع انه
يوم من الايام مهندس ولا دكتور ولا ضابط
ولا مسؤول في المجتمع ولا عمره المجتمع
حيصير
واحد تافه ما راح توقفه ما راح اتزوجه ما
راح تستقبله حيصير في المجالس يا جماعه
الخير بلغوا كلكم رجال امن كلكم
مدمن
شفت انك مروج بلغ اتق الله في عيالكم حنا
محاربين
وفي نعمه والله اني شفته اليوم في مكافحه
المخدرات والله لا يوصف بالكلام ولا باي
شيء اللي شفته واحد اللي شايفينه اليوم
واحد في المئه فيه
وقتهم مالهم
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا عبر الزوم من القسيمه
البروفيسور يوسف الاستاذ المشارك في
مكافحه الجريمه اهلا بكم معنا في تفاعلكم
وفي العربيه اولا نبدا بالحديث هل كان
متوقعا حجم هذا التفاعل الكبير مع حجم
الحمله القويه لمكافحه المخدرات داخل
السعوديه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله نعم بلا هذه الحمله
اتت على عده محاور
محور الشرعي بالخطباء
في المدارس محور الامني ولاحظنا حالات
القفز كثيره جدا على مهربي ومروج المخدرات
ايضا المحور التوعوي مع الاسر مع الاحيان
مع الانديه الى اخره فاتت هذه الحمله بعده
محاور لتكون شامله باذن الله لتقضي على
هذا الوفاه وفعلا بدات تؤتي اكلها طيب
بالحديث عن عده محاور ابرز هذه المحاور تم
تركيز هذه المره على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اهميه تركيز الحمله على مواقع
التواصل
لمتابعه وملاحقه المروجين للمخدرات
والمتاجرين بها خص
وصا لانه
التجار المخدرات ومروج المخدرات في المقام
الاول الشباب الشباب الصغار هؤلاء الشباب
سلاحهم الاول او طريقتهم الاهم والاكثر
حساسيه
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه من هنا اتت هذه
الحمله لتحاول ان تقضي على هذا على هذا
هذا الفساد وتحاول ان بدل ما يكون سلاح ضد
شبابنا يكون سلاح
لشبابنا ضد
المخدرات
لذلك من المهم جدا التعامل مع وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لتكون ايجابيه لتكون
مساعده بدل من كونها سلبيه لان ثبت ان
ارباب
المخدرات يستغلونها للتواصل مع الشباب من
هنا من المهم جدا ان الاهل
الامنيين ايضا اهل التوعيه الفكريه
الصحيحه يستخدمون هذا السلاح لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي للوصول الى شريحه
الشباب هذه هي الطريقه الاكثر الان شفنا
الفيديو للفنان فايز المالكي والتوعيه
التي
قام بها من خلال هذا الفيديو اهميه
التوعيه اهميه الشراكه المجتمع المحلي
والاسره في هذا الجانب
الكريم للاسف الشديد
التوعيه من من اهم من اهم وسائل الوقايه
من المخدرات الملاحظ ان بعض الاسر تعيش في
عالم اخر عن شبابها عن ابنائها عن بناتها
لذلك من المهم جدا توعيه الاسر من عده طرق
من الطريق الشرعي من الطريقه الامني
الجهه الامنيه تعرض ايضا من وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه للوصول الى الاسره لتوعيه
الاسره لان الاسره هي خط الدفاع الاول ضد
المخدرات
لذلك مهم جدا ان نعي الاسر
لان الاسره هي اول
ما اكثر او اسرع من من المدرسه من المسجد
من ايضا من الجهه الامنيه الام والاب هم
الاسرع والاخوه هم الاسرع عنده ملاحظه ان
هذا الشاب او هذا الشابه بدات في مراحل
الدخول في المخدرات او في عالم الادمان
لذلك من المهم ان نواعيهم النصر الى الى
هذه الاسر الى ارباب الاسر الاباء الامهات
الاخوه الاخوات
وننبهم على خطر هذه الخطيره جدا طب اللي
لفتني اضافه بروفيسور الى مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ادراج هذه الحمله والحرب ضد
المخدرات على الاعمال او الى الاعمال
الدراميه التي يحبها الجمهور كما شفناها
في طاش العوده اهميه ذلك
استقطاب الشباب
نعم هناك عدد من من الشباب والشابات
والاسر
الكبار السن تلعب الدراما لهم دور رئيسي
ودور مهم عندما تلقي المعلومه اكثر من
الرساله التوعيه احيانا تكون جافه
الدراما تلعب تلعب على على على الاحاسيس
على المشاعر على العواطف
بشكل جيد الحمد لله لذلك مهم جدا استغلال
جميع الوسائل مثل ما هو ارباب المخدرات
يستخدمون الان جميع الوسائل يجب ان نستخدم
جميع الوسائل لمنعها وضرب اماكنها وضرب
ايضا مروجيها ومهربيها بحيث نصل الى كل
شرائح المجتمع
شكرا جزيلا لك من القصيم حتى البروفيسور
يوسف الرميح الاستاذ المشارك في مكافحه
الجريمه شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد انتشر منذ ايام مقطع
فيديو لفتاه مصريه تدعى عهود محمد وهي
طالبه في كليه الطب الفيديو كان اثاره
جدلا وحاله من الغضب في الشارع المصري
الجديد اليوم هو بيان رسمي من وزارات
السياحه والاثار دعونا بدايه نشاهد
مكان محترم ومكان ناس محترمه بتيجي تقعد
تحجز فيه انت مكان اثبت ان انت مكان
الزباله ماشي ان انت
اكون انا حادثه 15 شهر
ان انا كنت حاجزه 15 شخص وتترد ال15 شخص
عشان انت عندك غلطه اللي في المسج اللي
بيبعتوها ما يبعتوش المفيد او ما ينفعش
محجبين زي اي مكان ثاني يبقى ده كده مكان
زباله
ولما حاولنا نتفاهم معاهم او نتكلم راحوا
قالوا الولد من الولد معانا اللي هم
هيكتبوا لنا الامن واللي احنا بنعمله ده
حاجه مش كويسه خالص من الف فايه بقى ده
اسمه ايه في تفاصيل الحادثه عهود ذهبت هي
وعدد من صديقاتها الى احد المطاعم في مصر
للاحتفال بعيد ميلادها لكنها تفاجات بان
العاملين في المكان لم يسمحوا لهن بالدخول
السبب هو تواجد صديقه محجبه بينهن المطعم
لم يخبرها مسبقا بانه يمنع دخول المحجبات
الى المكان او ان هناك قواعد محدده للباس
وبعد محاولات عديده هدد العاملون في
المطعم عهود وصديقاتها باستخدام رجال
الامن في حال عدم المغادره وبمجرد ما تم
نشر هذا الفيديو حتى اشتعلت منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي بالانتقادات والجدل حول هذه
الحادثه واغلبها درجه تحت مسمى العنصريه
وانه لا يجب ان يكون الحجاب اصلا ضمن
قواعد اللباس في المنشات وطلبوا الجهات
المعنيه باتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
من بعد كل هذا الجدل والمطالبات بالتدخل
الرسمي اصدرت وزاره السياحه والاثار بيانا
قالت فيه انه تم تشكيل لجنه لتحقيق في
الحادثه وعند زياره المطعم شوهد عدد من
العاملات المحجبات داخله بالاضافه الى
تواجد فتيات محجبات داخل المطعم تم
التاكيد من قبل اداره المنشاه السياحيه
بانها تستقبل زوارها من دون اي قيود او
حتى استثناءات هذا البيان تناقض بشكل كامل
مع ما تم نشره من قبل عهود وصديقاتها
وللان لم يصدر اي بيان رسمي من قبل اداره
المطعم
يواجه زوجان في مصر تهمه الاتجار بالبشر
بعد قيامهما بعرض طفلتهما رضيع البالغه من
العمر يومان فقط للبيع على فيسبوك حيث
اقدم الزوجه على عرض طفلتهما الرضيعه
للبيع مقابل 150 الف جنيه اي ما يقارب
خمسه الاف دولار السبب هو ضيق احوال
الاسره الماديه الزوجه تعمل في تنظيف
المنازل ودخلها غير ثابت اما دخل الزوج
فلا يكفيهم كاسره مكونه من خمسه افراد
فالزوج والزوجه لديهما ثلاثه ابناء اكبرهم
فتاه في العشرين من العمر وجميعهم لم
يحصلوا على التعليم خلال التحقيقات اعترفا
بفعلتهما بسبب الظروف الماديه الصعبه التي
يعانون منها قالت الزوجه انها لم تكن تنوي
الانجابه مجددا وانها طلبت من الاطباء
اجهاض طفله الاخيره لكنهم رفضوا ذلك اوضحت
بعدم اقتناعها بفكره بيع طفلتها في بدايه
الامر لكن زوجها اقنعها بذلك الزوجان الان
ينتظران محاكمتهما التي تم الى العشرين من
الشهر الجاري هذه ليست الحادثه الاولى في
مصر ويمكن ان نقول انها منتشره في اكثر من
دوله نسمع بها بين كل فتره واخرى وهنا
يجدر السؤال كيف يمكن ان يؤدي ضيق الاحوال
الماديه بالاباء لبيع ابنائهم ممكن
للانسان سيارته او منزله او اي شيء مادي
يمتلكه لكن قطعه من دمه وروحه كيف يمكن ان
يحدث ذلك وهو يمكن ان يكون هناك قد وصلنا
الى مرحله لم يعد الخوف من القانون
وتطبيقه راضيا لمن يقومون بمثل هذه
الافعال خاصه انها تعتبر جريمه وتندرج تحت
جريمه الاتجار بالبشر وعقوبتها تصل الى
السجن لست سنوات وغرامه ماليه كبيره جميع
هذه الاسئله تدور في اذهاننا والاجابات
تختلف طبعا بين شخص اخر
[موسيقى]
على كل بالموضع اللي بالعوده لموضوع
المطعم المثير للجدل في مصر ينضم الينا
لتعليق على الموضوع عبر الهاتف هشام وهبي
عضو غرفه المنشات السياحيه هشام اهلا بك
معنا في تفاعلكم العربيه اولا ما الذي حصل
تحديدا حول قضيه المطعم التي اثارت جدلا
كبيرا في مصر
مشاهدين
انقلع قرار النهارده
بيان رسمي من وزاره السياحه
بيؤكد عدم صحه ما تم تداوله عبر فيسبوك
بشان صيام احدى المنشات سياحيه بمنع دخول
المحجبات في النرواده
وانه لا يحق ايها منشاه فندقيه او سياحيه
منهج اولى محجبات في ضوء قانون المنشات
الفندقيه والسياحيه
حضرتك احنا اي بلاغ بيجي لازم بنتحقق منه
الاول تم تشكيل لجنه ونزلت لجنه تفتيش
بقياده الاستاذ علي حسن مدير الاداره
العامه للتفتيش على المطاعم السياحيه
بوزاره السياحه
تفتيش مفاجئ لقى انه في زبائن محجبات
موجودين داخل المطعم بالاضافه الى ثلاث
مواصفات محجبات شغالين داخل
هو ما فيش بلاغ هو تداول على صفحات
الفيسبوك
ناس عايزه تطلع ترند فبتعمل اي مشكله اي
حاجه منها
طيب الحادثه قبل
بدنا نتاكد
منك للقانونيه ليس هناك اي قيود او تقييد
لاي لبس معين داخل منشات سياحيه
سنه 23 بيمنع بيمنع اي مكان عام منشاه
سياحيه او فندقيه من التمييز ما بين
الزباين ممنوع يقول الزبون ما فيش دخول ده
اصل قانون طيب البنات استاذ هشام قاموا
بتصوير الفيديو كما شاهدنا داخل المطعم
واداره المطعم ردت بان الخطا كان من موظف
الذي الذي قام بالحج ولم يبلغهن بانه
المحجبات ممنوعات من الدخول الى المطعم
كيف ترون ذلك
باي طريقه علشان اطلع ترند واعمل مشكله
للمطعم
لانه البنت نفسها ما تقدمتش لحتى ببلاغ
رسمي للوزاره
يعني لو كان في مشكله كانت قدمت بلاش انما
هو مجرد خبر نشرته على صحتها على الفيسبوك
والناس تداولوه
ما فيش بلاغ رسمي ومع ذلك اتخذ الموضوع
على محمل الجد ونزلت لجنه عينه المكان
ودخلت المكان وشافت لقوا الكلام ده مش
صحيح طيب لماذا لم يكن هناك بلاغ او او رد
رسمي من قبل اداره المطعم بعد كل هذا
الجدل شاهدنا بيان من وزاره السياحه
والاثار لكن من اداره المطعم لم يكن هناك
اي تعليق سيدي هشام
وزاره السياحه هي المصدره
طيب في تفاعلكم لابد ان نسمع منك سيد هشام
يعني جميع المنشات التابعه لوزاره السياحه
والاثار ليست لديها اي قيود او استثناءات
ممنوع رفض دخول اي زبون مهما كان شكله
مهما كان لونه مهما كان جنسيه شكرا جزيلا
لك عبر الهاتف حدثنا هشام وهبي عضو غرفه
المنشات السياحيه
[موسيقى]
ساعات تفصلنا عن افتتاح واحده من افخم
المناطق الترفيهيه في الرياض منطقه
فياريال المصممه على طراز السلماني
المستمد من الهويه الوطنيه للمملكه وتعتبر
من المشاريع المميزه التي ستبرز هويه
العاصمه وتقدم تجربه ترفيهيه وثقافيه
والسياحيه مختلفه كان اكد رئيس مجلس اداره
هيئه الترفيه تركيا للشيخ النافيا رياض
تحفه معماريه وان الرياض تسابق نفسها
فياريا تتضمن عددا من صلاه السينما
والبرندات العالميه اضافه الى المطاعم
الفاخره وصاله الطعام في امريكا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بهذا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
التفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]